hello stephen krashen good morning Steve
Kaufman we are on the tain same timezone
and in many ways on the same wavelength
absolutely I have to tell you you've
been a great influence on my language
learning it's a real privilege to be
able to talk to you and to share now
with other people who are going to
follow this interview some of your
thoughts on language learning oh gosh
oh shucks I have to return the
compliment I've read your book I've
looked at I must I am now your student
officially Oh on your website I've been
doing Mandarin and Spanish and I greatly
admire what you've accomplished thank
you very much
no the there's a certain amount of
controversy still like for a believer in
input like me that the battle is over
but there is still a lot of controversy
there are people who say input only
won't do it you need grammar how much
grammar do you need how much output do
you need can you sort of and I'm sure
you've been at the sort of the eye of
the storm and so far - so far as all as
this controversy is concerned where do
you see your 5 theses today to what
extent has it with withstood the test of
time withstood the criticism and so
forth well I'll begin by quoting Paul
Simon still crazy after all these years
ok I think the hypotheses have held up
very very well let me give a little
historical perspective when all this
started in 1975 when we first stated
that there's something called a language
acquisition the first goal was to show
that acquisition is real at the time
people fully believed in what I call the
skill building hypothesis at first you
consciously learn something then you
practice it over and over again you get
feedback and eventually it becomes
automatic which I call a delayed
gratification hypothesis work hard study
do your grammar do your vocabulary and
someday you can actually use the
language you can understand it you can
speak it well the my claim is that the
gratification never comes it doesn't
work and it's painful and the
comprehension
the hypothesis says that you can have a
good time now you can enjoy yourself you
can listen to interesting stories go to
movies read good books and the result of
that is language ability very different
so the first task was to show that this
was real and I should say that this is
not my idea originally other people had
it before I did I have simply been
responsible for public relations before
I by the way do we have a lot of time
for this just cause you like I okay I
got some nice stories all right good
good good I hope people knew about it
before I did in the field of foreign
language teaching james asher TPR knew
about it before I did a Leonard Newmark
professor from University of San Diego
knew about it before I did
Harris win it's a scholar from Kansas
knew about it before I did and published
about it and I had read Asher's work
when I was a graduate student and I
thought this was just amazing now it
turns out this is going to get weirder
and weirder I went to my uncle's my aunt
and uncle's wedding anniversary 50th
anniversary Morrison and Newmark and
Leonard knew mark was there turns out we
have the same and uncle from different
sides of the family so Leonard knew mark
whose work I've very greatly been
influenced by who I admire we're on the
same wavelength
turns out to be more or less in the
family here's another one uh people in
other fields have come up with the same
hypothesis before I did Frank Smith and
Kenneth Goodman have hypothesized that
we learn to read by comprehension we
learn to read by understanding what's on
the text what's in the text and things
like spelling vocabulary most complex
rules of phonics are the result of
reading well Ken Goodman is married to a
very interesting lady named Yetta
Goodman who is a vigorous scholar and
hero of the field and we have always
been good friends and one time I was at
their house in in Arizona and I was
staying with them we were that close and
Ken says tea Etta
Yetta tell Steve the story of your
family the way you usually related and
she did it Kunta Kinte style in Yiddish
right which is her family language so
she started out in the other saying my
name is yet a Goodman originally Shapiro
my family I'm the granddaughter of blah
blah blah we come from this little
village shtetl called the dish anchor
and I said wait a minute
live dish anchor that's where my
father's family comes from Mary Ganesh
in which country in Eastern Europe it
keeps changing countries okay Poland
whatever exactly in that whole area so
and her Yiddish was highly
comprehensible to me turns out and yet
l'addition ker is a tiny little town of
3,000 and my family in Chicago always
went to l'addition ger picnics and
there's a little Carrera in the cemetery
and all this so yada and I have to be
relatives because it's such a tiny town
right and here we are I'm always honored
when I'm criticized in the same sentence
as Ken and yet a Goodman and it turns
out that we're related sort of related
to now yet as yet ish is much better
than mine my Yiddish is really fake from
German okay so she speaks a more pure
form and always scolds me for it but you
know so be it
so the theory is the idea of
comprehensible it is not mine it comes
from other people what I did is put it
in the context of a larger theoretical
framework and I've been gathering
evidence for it since 1975 in the
beginning the idea was to show that this
was real right and then study after
study yes it's real people get better
from just comprehensible input then the
research started to focus on grammar
which is your question
what about conscious grammar does that
play a role and I had hypothesized that
grammar is not bad it's not evil it's
not teach grammar go to jail it's just
that it's very very limited and its
primary function is for editing in order
to use it as an editor you know you're
about to save the sentence you think
about it in your mind and you make
little changes based on your conscious
knowledge rules but conditions have to
be met and these
very daunting conditions you have to
know the rule and we know only fragments
of language Cordia jeomsun right you
have to be thinking about correctness as
you're using it right and you have to
have time to apply the rule and what I'm
happy to say is that in the last 15
years there has been a parade of studies
in the professional journals attempting
to show that grammar is important to my
mind they all show that the impact of
grammar is there but it's limited I
think it can be useful
it's an adjunct but it's not the whole
thing it's a very peripheral part of any
language teaching program the way it is
helpful for most of us is when we write
because our versions of any language are
always a little different than the
accepted standard when you consider
English my first language your first
language there are little aspects of
written English that we do each of us
has our own idiosyncrasies they're
different from the standard for example
my favorite example is it's it's one
with the apostrophe one without
according to my scientific studies and
that's basically asking people to raise
their hands my conclusion is that
two-thirds of the well-read public has
acquired the it's it's rule another one
third and that includes me have not our
standards in written English are very
high so you got to get it right and I
think it's important that I know the
role and I can make these Corrections
when I edit it's limited but it's
helpful here and there so grammars that
it also gives you more confident all so
keep it out that makeup yeah I'll tell
you how I how I use grammar all right
good I find is that overwhelmingly I
learned the language through input I
learned the language subconsciously as
you say because the words for example
that I consciously learn are a very
small part of the tens of thousands of
words that I've had to learn in rockland
check just recently for example so i
acquire all this through my input
activities but with the grammar i also
acquire most of my familiarity with the
structure of the language through input
however
and I believe that the brain gets used
to it through this massive input like
again on link I have statistics showing
that I've I've read 150,000 words of
check so I've had and I've listened to
it all so I've had massive input however
some things I just don't notice I just
don't notice you know an example in
Russian you know one of something is I
think it's the degenerative singular
something two three four is another word
and five and more is another word you
may not notice that and so I keep my
little grammar book by the toilet and
when I'm sitting there I can sometimes
I'll flip through the grammar book and I
always find something that makes me
aware of something that I haven't
noticed before
so so to me the grammar much like the
output activities it makes you aware of
your gaps and improves your ability to
notice and helps the brain notice as the
brain is going through this you know the
main activity which is the listening and
reading so how do you deal is is that an
appropriate use of grammar does that in
any way I don't think it contradicts the
input hypothesis but it suggests that
grammar in that way helps you notice
things okay first of all I think the
stuff that you say you haven't noticed
it's probably very late acquired mmm-hmm
things like in French you know that
shows KJ please that little little
ending on the past participle late
acquired probably leaving the language
to in many cases does make a lot of
native speakers don't do it
also it's not are aspects like that and
when you see it in a grammar book and
it's simple because you've acquired most
of the language you can probably monitor
thoroughly well I find that when I speak
German or when I speak French languages
I know the best I monitor but not very
much just a few things here and there
so I can sound a little more educated my
favorite trick you know and play
nosotros is just nobody else should know
what you should do if you really want to
impress people as you get the
subjunctive wrong and then do self
correct and they think ah yes he's
really really so there are tricks like
that so I think yes that oops
and some people can do
but wait a minute look who you are I
accuse you Steve Kaufman of being a
member of a lunatic fringe and I am too
I am also in this group we are
fascinated by language fascinated by
grammar books fascinated by the rules we
are really far out there like point
0:01 of the human race I do what you do
I think my idea of a good time is
looking at a grammar book I don't know
just to see how the language is put
together we call this language
appreciation linguistics so there are
two requirements that have to be met
number one you have to have acquired
near a lot of the language already
number two you have to be as you and I
are very interested in the structure of
language per se
so with those constraints in mind
nothing wrong with it I just confess to
you I do to it to but compare that with
a beginning language student who hasn't
acquired even one percent of the
language and being forced to monitor the
whole thing now some language teachers
like us went into the profession people
like us because they love rules and they
teach them over and over again it gets
more and more obvious to them every time
they do it that that's the problem
the overwhelming you know hint of
grammar are beginning students and I
think that grammar as linguistics is
fine I think there's a general education
value to it
if I were I think high school secondary
school language arts and secondary
school advanced foreign language should
cover some linguistics small part of it
Chomsky's incredible ideas of language
universals bidding in a to universal and
the idea of language change in dialects
and how is language acquired but it's
not the main thing it's peripheral okay
well again on the subject of questions
another aspect of your hypotheses is the
idea that we should always be dealing
with first of all compelling and
interesting content I fully agree and
and that's where the enjoyment comes in
if it's interesting and compelling
content I'm turned on my brain is turned
on emotionally I'm committed to the
language I want to understand the
content that's all great however what
almost contradicts that is this
this n plus-1 a sheltered reading guided
readers graded readers I can't deal with
that I find that I got two or three
months of slogging through that kind of
simple stuff to get myself to a perch
where I now attack the real stuff with
40% unknown words my do I have link to
help because I can look up the words as
I go and I can save them but I have to
get myself into that meaningful
authentic you know content with
resonance as soon as I can or my
interest declines so how does that you
know conform to the idea of n plus-1
always that next level of difficulty i
think paul nation talks about 95 percent
95 percent yeah and known words well if
it were 95 percent known words i'd be
years acquiring the vocabulary that i
need in order to read Tolstoy or or or
listen to you know political discussions
on the television and so forth you have
just described the problem of language
teaching with capital P L and T this is
the problem let me restate the problem
what our research concludes what I think
is the best hypothesis is that for
language acquisition to happen input has
to be comprehensible and very
interesting even compelling I have done
the easy part me and my colleagues we've
done the easy part we've shown that this
is true application is the hard part
just the reason you talk about I'm going
to restate your question it's very easy
to give people input that's
comprehensible but not very interesting
that's school it's very easy to find
input that is interesting but not
comprehensible
that's real world language outside the
classroom and of course I must add that
many of my colleagues at the university
dedicated their entire careers to giving
us input that is neither interesting nor
comprehensible the problem of language
teaching is what you describe I think we
are approaching it gradually possibly
asymptotically the goal is for beginning
classes to be riveting and beginning
reading to be riveting and we're getting
closer
this is why I like methods such as TP RS
Blaine Ray's idea Wow you go to some of
these classes and they're amazing I went
to a demo across the street of
Pepperdine University which I helped set
up given by a guy who I think is one of
the best teachers of all time Dickinson
Fritz Fri tze free commercial for just
gave us a beginning lesson in Arabic
which had all of us at the edge of our
seats because he made it so much fun and
so interesting with incredible
personalization was about the people in
the class about them their opinions
gradually we're doing this and the
graded readers are getting better we
have not solved the problem we're
getting better and better and better
I'm trying to find interesting easy
input than Mandarin and as you know I've
I'm creating it myself
mostly because I can't find very much
other than that Terry Wallace has
written a couple of really interesting
books that you're both with full
characters and pinyon in Mandarin which
are helping when we add the Blaine and
his colleagues and trying to mention as
many people's names as I can here and
Karen Rowan and Carol Cobb have produced
a lot of good easy books and in Spanish
but we need a lot a lot more and they
need to get better and better this is
the problem we all have so all I can do
is restate it and say that I've done the
easy part meaning my colleagues have the
hard part is interesting in
comprehensible well you know I must say
that that I find that in my own language
learning because I don't have the time
to go to school and I've heard all about
TRS but I've never been in a TP RS
classroom I study on my own so if I look
at my real materials with with Czech and
Russian where there's an abundance of
phenomenal material on the internet
history politics things that interest me
that with link I'm able to pull these in
relatively early and fight my way
through 40% unknown words it doesn't
matter because I have the audio I'm
saving the words the words are
highlighted in yellow when I come across
them again because I forget that I've
ever looked them up and so that for me
as a perhaps maybe not a typical
language learner that works I'm not sure
it works
as well for the average person who
doesn't have the confidence in their own
language learning ability that I do and
so that's again well so that's a bit of
a problem that we're trying to deal with
I think a lot of our members have
created wonderful sort of diary of
taking my kids to zoo and stuff which if
you're learning Portuguese and you you
know you follow some lady in Belo
Horizonte and Brazil and her life that's
interesting and and it's made easy so
between you know going straight to the
literature there are these sort of
intermediate level high beginner level
things that our members are
spontaneously creating and where we have
the audio and we have the text and
sometimes we have notes so that is
providing a bit of a step you know in
that direction yeah yeah I think your
website is a real step forward in
providing this I also think that people
vary in their tolerance for noise right
some people require my colleague Steve
Sternfeld calls these battered language
students some people require completely
transparent input and that is where they
have at least the illusion that they're
understanding everything and the tipi
our classes try to do that which i think
is okay but it has its limits you can't
be transparent forever I'm kind of
between that level and you I'm now in
Spanish is pretty well down on my list
of competencies in language I'm kind of
low intermediate I can have a easy
conversation on everyday topics but
nothing complicated I'm now reading star
trek in Spanish right because I love
Star Trek okay and I can now say things
like you know Klingon man of war has
just D materialize out side the
starboard bow in several languages which
might help you never know uh but I'm I
understand about 60-70 sometimes eighty
percent if it were less than that I
couldn't do it okay I don't have the
degree but the trick is its compelling
for me I love the stories well that's
what I find if it's compelling I'll
fight my way through it but I recognize
as you say I call it sort of incertitude
like I'm quite happy to deal with things
that are fuzzy I don't have to know
exactly what this means you know I have
a I have a completely mistaken
understanding of what's in this sense it
doesn't matter to me you know and that's
why for example I always resent
in language class you know these
comprehension tests nevermind the
comprehension I got my half-baked you
know understanding of what was there
I'll revisit this everyone said I'll
understand it better not a problem but I
agree with you that maybe a lot of
people maybe most people are troubled
with that they want to nail things down
and I just find in language learning you
can't nail things down until eventually
I hope I hope people like that
eventually get over it there's a great
quote from John Holt in one of his
classes I think he was teaching fifth
grade a little girl came in will stew
and she was reading Moby Dick and he
said isn't it a little hard for you she
said no I just skipped the parts I don't
understand which we're willing to do
yeah which is great you know the long
descriptions so part of the strategies
people need to get is that you don't
have to know every word you can skip etc
and people are going to very I hope with
more experience in language this
requirement of transparency gradually
disappears right well which reminds me
it's just like the version here but one
of the things that has one of the things
that has interested me and in the
development of link is whether this
would have application for literacy
learning because every other reading
that I have done suggests that a vast
majority of people who are incarcerated
who are not call it successful in life
you know whether economically or
socially low self-esteem the whole works
are people who read poorly and so
obviously there's a percentage of people
can't decipher the letters but there's a
much larger section of people who simply
read poorly and I think where you
provide people with audio where you
provide them with a system for
accumulating words and tracking
statistically that in fact the
vocabulary is increasing as we do at
Linc wouldn't this have application for
people who are not sufficiently literate
in their own language to be successful
in the terms that we normally consider
people successful now we're talking
about people who are not good enough to
be independent readers like the idea
people who are in the lower 50% aisle
and there's a lot of these probably the
lower 10% I'll notice at least the
literacy advocates talk about you know
20 or 30 or 40 percent of people who are
quote functionally illiterate who have
trouble reading manuals at work who have
trouble
you know communicating effectively
reading more you know beyond the grade 7
level and so forth and so on
well if you're up to the grade 3 or 4
level you're pretty good Archie comics
and a lot of others are at the second
grade level
goosebumps starts at the 3rd grade level
some easy-easy novels Judy Blume all
this stuff which is great reading starts
about the fifth sixth grade level in
fact adolescent and young people's
literature today is better than adult
literature and we have comic books and
magazines bestsellers are at the seventh
grade level okay
so much I'm avoiding your question for
the Ryan because that's something else
much of the problem people have in
prison is a lack of access to
interesting books and I have
single-handedly decided to solve the
problem myself and I'll tell you about
the heroic action that I've been taking
I joined a group called book muqaam
that's how I'm getting booking books in
other languages cheaply you put all the
books on your shelf that you have that
you want to get rid of and you know
people like us we don't want to just
give books away to charities we want to
give them to people who want those books
right so I list my book my book on book
much like I have an extra copy of a
biography of Gandhi someone from New
Jersey wants it requests it I send to
them I pay the postage I get a point I
can then use the point to request other
books so I use this to get books in
other languages from other countries
book much is one of the only groups that
does other countries that's book müjgan
Islam yeah I love okay at the end of the
year here's where I've been
single-handedly solving the literacy
crisis at the end of the year I have
extra points I may have 50 points extra
at the end of the year you can donate
the points to libraries and I always
donate my points to prison libraries and
school libraries at the end of the year
so if every middle class person did this
in the world school libraries and prison
libraries would be very well stocked
okay that that's that's my scheme now
people in prison a lot of them just need
a lot of interesting stuff to read but
the basic lower lower lower levels
nearly every method works some work
faster than others everybody who goes to
school
in North America reaches that basic
second third fourth grade level the way
to get beyond that this theory voluntary
massive reading this is in first
language in second language where you
don't have a chance to hear it the link
webs like might be very good I don't
know they would be good study to do okay
yeah no I that's one thing I'd be quite
interested I've approached various
organizations and of course they all
hold up their nose oh you're for profit
you're this debt and I've never had
anyone willing to pay any attention to
what we're doing but that's a oh my gosh
that's outrageous because the profit
people are running education in the
United States and are very open about it
the whole common core standards is
nothing but a big economic ripoff for
the point oh one percent you can quote
me on that anyway yes yeah third I would
like to follow up because I think what
obviously in our society the better we
read the better people do economically
individually their lives are better the
whole society does better it's it's just
a wrapper goes the other way around the
wealthy classes the people who are
middle class have access to books
therefore they all read better in their
kids no I agree with you
I agree with you anyway okay let's get
back to the sort of foreign language
acquisition I've seen some very
motivated people like I attended this
American conference for teachers of
foreign languages whatever I met a lady
there whose name I can't remember at the
University of San Diego and she's and a
number of the teachers were very modern
I must say I was overall overall very
very impressed and yet the results of
language teaching in our schools if I
look at French instruction in Canada to
the English speaking school system and
I've heard it's the same with regard to
Spanish which is the big foreign
language in the United States that
despite all of these very motivated
dedicated many of them very fluent in
the language they're teaching even
though they're not necessarily native
speakers yet yet the results are so poor
and there's been umpteen you know
examples of research I mean if you
compare like 30 years ago 50 years ago
things have been researched to death and
I'm not sure that there's been any
progress at all so you know when we'll
go to all of this research directed in
better results in terms of language
instruction in our school
system okay let me begin by restating
what you said and give more evidence
that you're right
the state of affairs in foreign language
is really pathological because we know
that the kids who do well say in college
classes are the ones who had it in high
school already we are called false
beginners and they're the ones who
dominate the class and go on and dooba
the true beginners getting nowhere and
really go to intermediate classes like
literature it's filled with native
speakers or students who have been to
the country for several years who've
been to Europe or spend some time in
Quebec and then take intermediate French
literature etc so the whole thing is is
a charade in my opinion it always has
been and again what you suggest which is
all I'll spell out because it makes me
look good
is that comprehensible input based
methods have been shown again and again
no exceptions we have won every single
method comparison study since the 1960s
every time you pick comprehensible input
against traditional language teaching we
win on tests of communication our kids
are much better on tests and grammar
there's either no difference our kids
are a little better and our kids are far
more likely to continue is true
beginning methods it's true of
intermediate methods content-based
shelter we know that reading is very
powerful one of my favorite studies I
was part of we looked at subjunctive
among Spanish speakers kids who've
studied Spanish and the only predictor
that counted it wasn't how much you
studied it it wasn't how long you lived
in the country it was reading reading
for pleasure so we know over and over
again why haven't people done this a
good question I wish I knew this is my
failure to master the art of public
relations and get this around one source
of opposition is natural and acceptable
and that is the loyal opposition
whenever something new comes out it is
the scientists obligation to question it
and get started and do studies etc my
problem is that those who attacked it
have not thoroughly understood the
theory or even superficially understood
the theory
so there so when they see a tiny little
speck that says the grammar might help
here and there
they then assume the grammar is
wonderful and that's all we should ever
do there's also frankly an economic
force if this is right the textbooks are
out of business
most of them I and we have to
drastically retool another way out is to
take the step that you've taken that I
do and that is focus on independent
language acquisition what can people do
on their own and websites such as yours
and other people who work with
independent students this is a wonderful
way around it I'm all for it my
colleagues Jeff McQuillan and Lucy say
have a very nice ESL pod back calm and
whoa boy they've been more good than I
have because they just give people
people have had a little English in
school worldwide comprehensible text
comprehensible things now to listen to I
hope they're having that and this is
helping a lot of people everywhere and
they write I'm sure they have about
50,000 subscribers it's great it's
terrific it's what needs to be done a
point you made when you read an art when
you posted a comment about rosetta stone
I thought was very important and what
you've made again here and that is we
have to set up opportunities for
independent acquisition just like you I
don't have time most people don't have
time I do my listening when I'm on the
elliptical machine right Gold's Gym yeah
which is now my my affiliation mount USC
when you know when I go for walks it
Center in the car and reading when I
have time through the day you know when
I'm in security lines and airports pilot
says put your tray tables down and I'm
waiting for elevators in bed at night so
we need to service these people provide
them with interesting text to listen to
interesting things to listen to and I
think this might change the field more
rapidly than anything so keep up the
good work all right I will you know
Steve and I I have the impression we
could go on for a long long time and
what I would like to do is is end the
sort of official part of the interview
and thank you very much for doing this
and I'm sure that my viewers of my
youtube channel will really really
appreciate this and then I could maybe
have a few words
you after the I shut down the video so
it's a deal
thank you Steve okay thank you very very
much